two-time FIFA Women's World Cup champion
two-time FIFA Player of the Year
two-time Olympic gold medalist as a
matter of fact scoring the gold medal
winning goals in the finals in the
Summer Olympics in Beijing and then four
years later in London first person to
ever score three goals in the FIFA
Women's World Cup final as she did
against Japan in 2015 and most
importantly for you know if you don't
mind for me also the first to do all
that and be a correspondent on NFL the
grind on epochs tonight Wednesday 9:00
Eastern Time helped to promote that and
her work covering the Eagles and
Patriots none other than Carli Lloyd how
are you Carly good how would you like
that
being part of the paparazzi covering a
football team contest look Jerry I was
very interesting it was obviously a new
experience for me but I really enjoyed
it you know at first I'm like of course
I can't do this
I usually I'm the one getting
interviewed Brooke but no it was a it
was a lot of fun I'm really glad I did
it
it was you know definitely out of my
wheel force a little bit but it was
great I thought it was was fantastic and
enjoyed it alright so let's walk through
it are the Eagles your team if you have
one Carly are they your team would you
say they are yeah I've been a I've been
a silly sports fan my whole life I'm
just growing up over the cross bridge in
New Jersey no I've always rooted for for
all the sports teams I would say you
know football watching the Eagles is
probably my my second sport that I
watched the most besides soccer okay and
so obviously being around the Eagles
then would be something comfortable for
you too and I imagine you know Zach Ertz
is well through your teammate Julie
correct would that be a safe assumption
definitely yeah it was it was great to
be a part of that I mean I met I think I
met everybody and you know that the top
execs in in the office for the Eagles
all on the sidelines and in the course
of an hour so it was it was really cool
to kind of be able to see you know what
everything entails I mean it's obviously
way different than a soccer game there's
way more people it
was really it was really cool and Zach
was gracious enough for me to you know
kind of bug him I know as an athlete
we've got a routine and I definitely
didn't want to you know kind of uh you
know mess up any sort of routine or if
he had but he was very gracious enough
and yeah he's a great guy class guy one
of the best tight ends and he's been
exciting to watch since he's come to
Philly I haven't seen the finished
product yet that's on tonight at
Wednesday 9:00 Eastern Time I've got a
link on my on my phone right now I'll be
checking it out later before it airs
tonight on FX but have you did you cross
paths with any Patriots as well I didn't
I mean you know you you've got to tip
your hat off to the Patriots I know
there's you know if I said this in front
of Eagles fans they probably they'd
probably start throwing things at me but
yeah you've got a he's got to respect
people that are really good at what they
do and so I have a huge amount of
respect her Belichick in and Tom Brady
didn't get to meet them but you know
maybe our paths will cross at some point
but you know as I thought the Eagles
were going to do it at one point this
unfortunate to not come away with it but
I thought you know Zach given the game
had a had a good game and caught some
some good catches that were important
and you know he did what he could do so
it was good to see Carli Lloyd here on
the Rich Eisen show one piece of video
that I have seen including one that I
just showed on on the air here was you
attempting what appeared to be a 27-yard
field goal in a sweater coat and runners
and we we didn't see the result but we
saw the kick and it looked it looked
true Carly yeah took probably five or
six of those they all went when in the
uprights okay you know so that was that
was good I didn't have my obviously my
normal attire on but yeah you don't
believe it or not it's there's obviously
a lot of other things that you know are
a bit challenging with you know big men
on the line and people running at you
but
I have done it in pads and a helmet okay
and did the two-step
so I've I've realized that I can I can
do it with with all that stuff so it's
just a matter of you know fine-tuning
some things and then seeing where we're
at I mean first and foremost I'm
focusing on soccer right now and want to
be a part of the Olympics this summer
but you know anything's possible so in
that regard because again it we saw
video of you doing it in training camp
and crushing it and then a serious
conversation did break out I mean were
you close to signing with an NFL team
Carly yeah was it was pretty close I had
two you know two offers to to come play
in the fourth preseason game I mean that
would have been the most ideal scenario
given the larger roster that they have
but I had a little bit of a dilemma
because I had a game myself at the link
so I wasn't able to do it but yeah it
was it was pretty crazy I mean I I got
home in the car I think an hour after
the kick in you know the next thing I
know it's it's gone viral there's
there's people wondering what team I'm
gonna sign for and you know kind of
getting some of these these calls from a
couple of teams so it was it was a
pretty pretty crazy moment I would say
you know it's still somewhat going on
there's still some of that buzz but it
you know it was it was non-stop for
several weeks after the kick I bet I bet
so which teams knocked on your door
Carli Lloyd
I've been keeping that keeping that
between myself and my husband for now
there are nobody nobody knows yet
I don't want to pry what was any of them
on in the Eastern time zone any Eastern
time zone teams I don't know another in
this country so yeah there's no there's
nobody outside the country in the NFL
okay is it an animal team was a team an
animal all is it a can you give me that
I don't know I can't can't can't
disclose okay so
wondering okay so one was the last time
and so so let's just put it this way it
is something that should say next year
roll around you get through the Olympics
that you would entertain if a team was
also as serious as you were on the
subject for you to try and literally
make a national football league team and
do this as a professional National
Football League player yeah absolutely
yeah I mean I you know I don't this
isn't just a publicity stunt or
something that I'm you know having fun
just kind of stringing the media along I
mean I I know that I can you know do it
I know that I have the mental capacity
in pressure situations I know that there
be loads of people that would want to
see me fail that's no different than the
entire the entirety of my career loads
and loads of people never thought that I
could get to this point as well and my
soccer career so yeah I definitely want
to entertain it but I want to be good at
it and I want to be able to do it and
that that's ultimately what it comes
down to and if I can help kind of
pioneer and break down some doors for
for other women in the future that would
be amazing
well I got I got to tell you Carli Lloyd
I have a six-year-old daughter
very rarely I've never once do I recall
pointing out a placekicker to her I
certainly would if you were the one and
she's getting ready for her final game
in the AYSO with the purple lightning
this weekend if you do hear about the
final results about that team you might
be able to hear that but I I'm I think
for sure that would mean so much to so
many people what would it mean to you
for you to actually go ahead and
accomplish that should you be able to I
mean I think that you know it's what
it's all about I mean I if I was a
little girl you know watching football
and if I saw you know a female kicking
you know that would instantaneously make
me want to try to do that because I've
always been a you know growing up I was
always a kid who had no fear of trying
different things I had no fear jumping
in with the boys and playing with them
and trying to
better than them and you know I just
wasn't fearful of maybe not being good
at something right away but then you
know with practice becoming better at it
so I think that it would just give you
know all of these you know females and
and just people around the world a
different perspective and there's been
you know women out there who have been
so successful and who has broken down
doors and barriers and been the first to
do something to help pave the way for so
many other people so if if I could help
do that that's really ultimately what
it's all about so we'll see what happens
you know I'm definitely definitely
entertaining it and and want to make
sure that I could you know do it do it
right and do it well well one thing's
for sure Carli Lloyd you'd be paid
equally as everybody else I know you
know it's it's crazy I was just talking
to somebody about this the buzz and it
just goes to show you how big the NFL is
because I think I've gotten more press
and more coverage potentially probably
than my whole soccer career you know and
soccer is pretty big here women's soccer
is pretty big we've been successful but
the NFL and and male sports who is
totally in a different limelight and you
know it's it's crazy and we just have to
keep keep pushing on and keep making
things better because you know
ultimately that's that's really what
it's all about
well I Carly Lord here a few minutes
left with Carli Lloyd tonight on NFL the
grind on Epix hanging out with the
Eagles prior to their game with the
Patriots right here on the Rich Eisen
show few more minutes left you know I
know you're out there in France and
you're taking care of business and
obviously in previous World Cups and and
I'm you know somebody who's thrilled to
be able to put a roof over my head
having talked about the NFL with the NFL
Network for 16 years and and I am
thrilled how big the NFL is what you and
your compatriots did for the US soccer
scene for u.s. women's soccer but the
u.s. in period this is the United States
period it was pretty darn huge here this
summer Carly I mean you couldn't go
anywhere without anybody talking about
it i-i've very rarely been had somebody
call me up and say hey you know if you
have somebody from the US Women's
National Team come in studio you got to
let me know because I want to bring my I
want to bring my kid nobody really says
hey if you have somebody from this movie
or someone from that team on I don't get
that but I got it this summer
I don't know were you aware are you
aware of that Carly I think it's hard I
think it's hard when you're when you're
over there you're preparing you know we
were there for for over a month you you
kind of just shut the world the outside
world off you're in a different country
so you're not really hearing too much
but you know we knew that that this was
this was big and to go back to back and
win was unbelievable accomplishment so
it was it was great that we were able to
kind of transform the sport into a
different into you know a little bit of
a different light it was incredible and
I think that we we've continued to you
know fight obviously for equality and an
equal pay and all that you know it's
been it's been amazing and I think we're
not only setting setting the standard to
make things better here in the US for
for women and girls who are going to
come and play on this national team in
the future but we're setting the
standard for countries all over the
world you know you look at Australia
women's women's team they've now reached
an agreement with their Federation to be
paid equally as their male counterparts
so there's more and more teams and more
and more countries who were who are
hiding and we're making it better and I
think you know what people don't realize
is that we've have we have to work so
much harder off the field
I remember in 2015 after one in the
World Cup my life changed my teammates
life's changed but I had to get back
into playing play for my club team play
for the national team and I had to take
every single opportunity and endorsement
and appearance on I mean I was running
myself ragged for you know a year to
year
because we have to work so much harder
off the field to earn a living and and
be able to you know sustain this
lifestyle and being able to put money
away for a future so it's got to be
better you know we we should have to
first and foremost should put all our
time and efforts on the field and not
have to work as hard off the field but
that's the world we're at now and
hopefully into time it will be be better
and a bit more balanced well I know
you're speaking at Cornell next month on
this subject is there any update you can
give me on on the lawsuit and what's
going on well with the US Women's
National Team on that front
not not particularly since you know
everything's kind of a discovery period
and we're you know kind of have the
attorneys involved but yes it's ongoing
and you know hopefully we could maybe
reach an agreement pretrial but yeah
it's ongoing and we'll see what happens
in that in that regard Carli Lloyd I
really appreciate the time have a great
time I guess watching the broadcast
tonight on epics and do me a favor call
me after you sign with the bears okay
Carly yeah I've been getting a lot of
requests okay or call me after you sign
with the Jets thank you see did I get a
confirmation or denial Chris what do you
think I'm just fishing I'm fishing the
logs in the water thanks for doing that
show it's a it's a pretty neat show with
NFL Films it's pretty cool I someone
from South Jersey being with NFL Films
in Philadelphia I hope you enjoyed the
experience
yeah I'm looking forward to seeing it
tonight well enjoy it karlie thanks for
the call we'll chat soon all right take
care you bet that's at Carli Lloyd on
both Twitter and Instagram for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on VR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app